spider warren spider-worn radioactive
spider-worn it's been a while since we
covered a cosmic wonder video warren i'm
gonna text you telling you i hate your
video anyway
um did you just call me oh damn all
right we're gonna watch today we're
causing wonder spider-man 4 and the
amazing spider-man 3 update gonna be
enjoying this video if you leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated anyhow
[Music]
so today's report is coming from daniel
rbk i'm sure if you kept up with
spider-man knowing home all of the leaks
all the rumors everything that was going
around you know who he is and he did a
video on his youtube channel recently
talking about everything that he's heard
so far about andrew garfield and toby
mcguire returning for future spider-man
projects in fact the title of his video
was spider-man future projects with
andrew garfield now he starts off by
saying that that's conclusive marvel
studios and sony found massive success
with spider-man no way home and the
other two spider-man returning and due
to the success they are obviously open
to them returning for future spider-man
projects but daniel rpk specifically
states that what he has heard coming
straight from him is that toby and
andrew will indeed return toby and
andrew seem more than happy to come back
for spider-man no way home and in some
of the behind-the-scenes videos and
interview videos toby even said he's
kind of up for anything so this doesn't
come as that big of a surprise it's just
kind of crazy to you know pause and
think about the fact of how we didn't
even know if this was really going to
happen if this was like just a
possibility on the horizon and the fact
that we will probably more than likely
get more projects with them now which
makes me wonder how this one movie like
we saw how avengers change cinema and
i'm wondering how this precedent could
change cinema moving forward too as well
it's gonna be gnarly to see and the fact
that we have like toby and andrew back
which both seem like they ended with not
the best of terms and now they seem so
enthused yeah and even sam raimi was
like it'd be beautiful to do another
spider-man or something like that which
i feel like you know everyone's vibes
especially off of the way everyone left
off have way improved so daniel goes on
to state that something is in the works
right now something with either andrew
or toby or perhaps even both now he says
that it's not concrete at this point
meaning he doesn't really know what it's
going to be he says he doesn't know if
it's going to be a quick little cameo
and perhaps the multiverse so maybe a
cameo in multiverse of madness like
we've been hearing for some time now
although we haven't really heard much
about toby in multiversal madness
recently he still very well could appear
in the film so daniel says it could be a
quick cameo in a multiverse movie or
another movie or it could be a full
blown out spider-man 4 or tasm 3. and
obviously i think this is so all
possibilities they would want another
full movie with andrew garfield with
toby maguire or perhaps both of them or
even bring tom holland back as well and
the three of them be in a movie together
why doesn't sony just do a movie called
spider-man i know
perfect a whole movie with just the
three of them i think that would just be
incredibly special who have to fight a
really just crazy villain and also learn
a lot about themselves
nah
i just want quips they should fight
michael morbius
fight michael morbius that's all i want
green light morbius two you cowards we
did hear a rumor not too long ago that
was talking about maybe a movie with
andrew garfield and toby just the two of
them together going kind of across the
multiverse i don't know if there's any
legitimacy to that rumor at all but that
is actually a movie that i really
wouldn't mind seeing i think it would be
pretty funny and pretty cool here's the
thing i would only want a crossover
movie with them again if marvel is
working with them on it that's why i'm
not excited for like the idea of a toby
and andrew film because as cool as it
sounds in theory like i don't feel like
if they're not working with marvel on
this it would be that good yeah
absolutely and two i don't know i feel
like it would actually feel the most
complete if they had all three of them
because of that brotherly bond i almost
feel like with two of them it would be
cool but it would also feel like
something's a little missing but right
now it looks like we have a few
different options of what could happen
with toby and andrew and it does seem
like they are returning sony wants it
plus andrew and toby probably want it as
well in fact andrew garfield was
recently asked about the amazing
spider-man 3 and if it was going to be
made and this is what he said no update
from me no one's going to believe me
anything i say ever again and that's my
problem and that's true he went around
for i think way to take responsibility
for talking about how he wasn't the
werewolf and he's not in spider-man
knowing home and then of course he was
and of course that's not his fault no
one blames him for that that's what he
had to do but let's just put it this way
if tasm 3 is going to be made he's
definitely not going to be the one
that's going to tell us it's being made
but check out this very interesting i
mean this is coming from morbius
director daniel espinoza and it's about
the post post-credit scenes in morbius
and i won't really spoil anything but
let's just say it's heavily implied that
spider-man has a future in sony's
spider-man universe i recently said that
thanks to the post-credits scenes for
morbius i'm not really sure that sony
has any type of plan for spider-man i
think they might have an idea of what
they want to do but they're kind of just
winging it right now however it appears
right off of what daniel espinoza said
that maybe they do here's what he said i
think that the future is very exciting
and i think that the plans that sony has
in very closed rooms that i'm not really
allowed to attend or the small snippets
i've heard fills me with joy but if i
said anything they would shoot me on the
spot so this actually sounds pretty
decent he says that sony has a very very
tight team working on the future of the
spider heading out well
teams are tight
he's not allowed in that closed door
he's not allowed to hear what that team
is working on even though he just worked
on a film that exists in the spider-man
universe so i'm starting to think that
maybe just morbius unfortunately had to
suffer with big changes made to it
because of the delay it was delayed over
two years and a lot happened in those
two years including spider-man no way
home so sony's plans probably changed
and stuff got cut from morbius and the
film kinda just took a hit unfortunately
i'm not gonna lie after morbius my hopes
for tasm three
really went down
not the fact that like it needs to get
made it got me worried about how sony
would handle it i really wanted it i i
still do
ultimately i think it would be really
cool to have however when it comes to
like venom let there be cartage and
morbius
uh you know i i don't want a 1003 where
i walk out going it's fine i wish that
we didn't do that actually yeah and i
mean even though they're perfectly
capable of finding quality directors to
make these things in sony's hands alone
i am much more wary of what they would
decide to do because i just don't know
if it's gonna get the time love and
attention that it would need to really
be everything we want it to be the good
news is is that it does look like sony
has somewhat of a plan and they're being
very secretive about that which is good
and also pretty expected especially
after spider-man no way home i mean we
all knew about toby and andrew being in
the film basically two years before it
came out so the fact that daniel
espinoza the director of morbius a movie
in their spider-man universe wasn't
allowed in this tiny closed door this
tiny room of people who knows what the
future has in store for the spider verse
means that they really are trying to do
everything they can to keep everything a
secret even though we are hearing that
toby
that doesn't mean it's a good plan
though
maybe they just kept him out cause he
directed morbius however i do think i
would like some type of confirmation
that spider-man 4 is going to be made or
the amazing spider-man 3 is going to be
made i don't need to know the entire
movie i just would like a confirmation
that it's going to happen and it looks
like i don't want to know till release
day according to daniel richmond sony is
talking about that right now they have
things in plan and hopefully this secret
plan that sony has for their spider-man
universe will be revealed soon but let
me know what you think about all of this
news in the comments down below and
would you choose a spider-man 4 movie
with tobey maguire or would you choose a
the amazing spider-man 3 movie with
andrew garfield if you had to choose one
i'll probably ultimately choose the
amazing spider-man 3 so we can close out
that chapter all right guys well what do
you want spider-man 4 or amazing
spider-man 3. leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell leave a
like
and we'll catch you guys soon